yeah that was a big barbecue that some
of the guys went to it yes JD who
enjoyed the Rose a wine that was served
at the barbecue he's you know he's a
wine you like the rose a it's a nice
wine to have on a on a sunny day Sunday
night whatever how would you describe
the taste of this Rose oh it was smooth
smooth have you had wine that is rough
with lots of tannins yes tannins what a
hint of filet-o-fish was it funny I was
perfect for a moonlit afternoon like
mayonnaise you got married and you know
like the glass is pink
oh you know how do you hold a wine glass
well I know your sister hold it by the
stem but I feel like I need I had the
supportive more so I do hold it by the
glass the you know the bowl whatever I
rested on my stomach so you're saying
that you know that when people drink
wine they're supposed to hold the stem
but you're saying you can't get a good
grip on the stem yeah I think it's more
it's it's okay to do it when you have a
red wine but when you have white since
it's cold it's supposed to be cold this
thing you're not supposed to hold it by
the glass because it's was a little warm
it up more or something or something or
something I like the new JD I'll try it
listen to this someone told me this and
I don't even believe it oh god JD and
his wife bring their own his-and-hers
matching wine glasses to events my wife
got these glasses and she wanted to
bring him out so we'd brought him why
would you bring him out into somebody
else's house it was like an outside
thing so there were no glass
so people were just drinking straight
from the bottle and you guys had glass
like plastic cups and stuff told Jesus
sophistication yeah JD has glasses will
travel mr. K - JD I never thought that
would happen when I met this guy hardly
show up at the party and barely wore
shoes well we met JD he was like now
remember the movie Jodie Foster she was
raised in the woods by no one
I went from caveman to George Clooney
when he first started the interns used
to like run away from him most
frightening JD had written a movie about
an axe murderer and everybody thought it
was like a story about himself I'm sure
my hygiene wasn't as good then and you
know what you live and learn
know you've learned you learned through
embarrassment on this show